einen us präsidenten seines amtes zu
entheben ist schwierig und auch noch nie
passiert entweder der präsident müsse in
einem komplizierten verfahren für
amtsunfähig erklärt werden aus
gesundheitlichen gründen das gab es noch
nie die andere möglichkeit ist ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren um dieses
engagement einzuleiten muss der verdacht
bestehen dass der präsident hochverrat
bestechung oder andere schwere
verbrechen oder vergehen begangen hat
auch machtmissbrauch kann ein grund für
eine impeachment sein
das parlamentarische verfahren kann
jedes mitglied des repräsentantenhauses
einleiten dann untersucht dessen
rechtsausschuss die vorwürfe wenn er sie
für schlüssig hält stimmen die 435
abgeordneten darüber ab ob vor der
anderen kammer des kongresses dem senat
anklage erhoben werden soll
der senat ist nun eine art gericht
der vorsitzende des obersten
gerichtshofs kommt dazu er leitet das
verfahren am ende müssen zwei drittel
der senatoren der amtsenthebung
zustimmen
in der geschichte wäre es fast zwei mal
dazu gekommen 1868 gegen andrew johnson
weil dieser angeblich gegen rechte des
kongresses verstoßen hatte und 1998
gegen bill clinton wegen meineids und
behinderung der justiz in der
lewinsky-affäre in beiden fällen fand
sich im senat keine ausreichende
mehrheit im watergate-skandal 1974 trat
richard nixon vor einer amtsenthebung
lieber selbst zurück